[Music]
hey screen junkies pumpkin the what's in
the box I'm Harold come on okay man
we're gonna answer the immortal question
what's in the box we can only do that
once he whipped something sharp out not
gonna be his brain probably gonna be
this thing use the nut snikt Oh God like
Wolverine would cook alright let's find
out what's in the box oh oh come on kids
we got us a boatload of Waterworld
my figures walk down memory lane years
ago there was this movie Waterworld the
Kevin Costner is and that was largely
regarded as the most expensive like flop
in movie history I actually like this
movie me too me too
there's one moment in this movie where
like he throws our food at the dude
sleep the dude looks Kevin Costner goes
like that it's like hi it was this far
we're gonna have such a cool moment
right here you got the Mariner your main
character is the Mariner that was the
name that they gave Kevin Costner he had
gills in the movie yeah Geils ever since
Kevin Costner breathe in the morning
Costner allowed Kenner to use his
likeness on the figure he originally
said no on Prince of Thieves so if you
want to get a rod new Prince of Thieves
figure Robin Hood didn't look like Kevin
Costner but if you want to get a
Waterworld figure his character the
Mariner looked like Kevin Kahn what do
you think that is do you think he was
like yes because they were like Popeyes
in 10 million bucks in his pocket
I'm sure money played a role but look
he's got it hearing - he also had a
killer mode this for those of you who
always like I've always wanted to play
blue velvet this is your Dennis Hopper
action figure right here man so you're
halfway to plain blue velvet you go get
a comic lockland figure you're you're
all the way there
sure no this is Nord I don't know who
played Nord man looks like Patrick
Swayze and then there's one last guy
which is the smoker thunder ski with a
busy again yes so it's just a dude on a
killer jet ski man open up the trimaran
if these were Star Wars toys this would
be like an x-wing I'm thinking more like
a Millennium Falcon right here dude on
the box and on the packaging it says not
intended for water use so right away
you're like oh my god thank you mom
we're gonna play Waterworld let's put it
in the tub and there's so many holes in
this you put it in the top of its sink
and the adventure would be over all of
this is predicated on being in the water
so if you're not playing with this in a
tub or pool or at least a toilet you're
losing out on all the effects of walnuts
you're right you're like wait I'm
playing Waterworld but not on the water
so many kids went on ritalin after they
bought these toys because they were like
oh you give me a - I can't play with
mother
he's a wheel this wheel cuz you can play
with it on work just like they did in
the movie of course not it was all on
water and stuff the premise of
Waterworld was that polar ice caps
melted if I remember correctly
mm-hmm and that's why there was no land
anywhere that's why sand was that a
premium dairy even if all the ice caps
melted the ocean would only rise a few
hundred feet do you know why you know
why the sand was was important right
because of his proof that there it was
possibly land out there in the world you
know yeah yeah you're like the Rain Man
of Waterworld feel like I remember
everything there is a special place with
sand and beaches if Randy can want her
to get there but the movie was so
expensive shoot a movie on water man
talked to Spielberg we read all those
books about Jaws it was like nearly
impossible but I bet you I thought they
when they were making this movie that
like you know Spielberg had a tough on
Jaws we might be making the new jaws let
me tell you it was not the new jobs
actually it did wind up doing like six
times so but did you see in a theater no
you're put trying to put together
without once looking at instructions on
how to do so this is why I never plays
with you as a child because you're like
this just put it together
you're smashing things enough yeah I
know get out supposed to go this one
goes in the middle
let me go this one goes here I'm
probably getting it in the hall brother
I've heard that about this this could be
fun
insert the mast into the into place
attach power blades to me that's insane
that doesn't sound good at all
[Applause]
look what it did fun is over it's no
longer water world's broken world don't
ever touch anything on my boat again it
wouldn't float in water before it's
definitely not gonna blow now make this
part work list there you go I can get it
in because this promise is good times
whirling blades okay we gotta get to
play good look at this cartoon action it
shows them going fast like we could make
a margarita with this when it's done
it's so look how much fun that promise
yeah okay god this insert the boom into
the set I'll expect you to know marital
mayor you know Mariner terms and stuff
oh it's very soon I'm not nautical I was
on a catamaran once when I was a kid
with my family and like the netting you
sit in my netting I was in the water my
family they were all fine then I was
like is this broken and they looked at
me sad like you're broken
Kevin 21-inch high-mass dude I can get a
21 inch mass yeah cuz does to us
oh snap son this is where that thing
hides - Gary go see that oh you can go
under the four boards and stuff your
builder like you're like I ain't got
time for jokes I'm doing this right
without tools no less if funds abs like
my dad's has been this much time
building mokra or breaking my toys
either but I think you'd be amazing in
here or my father and you were like
let's put this together here's a toy
from a 30 each one comes with a weird
sea animal that you would never play
with and real fun none of them appeared
in the movie I remember the movie there
were no there were barely any fish in
this guy gets an eel what is it a mutant
moray eel this one gets a mutant squid
mutant hunter shark that doesn't look
like a shark and this has got to be let
me guess mutant crab yes Oh mutant crab
so I opened up all the toys here man
look at this this guy shoots stuff now
did it have a real pain action Kenner
was gonna make a boba fett that shot a
rocket out of his back and then oh what
kids might eat it by the time they got
around a water world they were like I'm
kid up there carrot kid shows up as ice
and they started oh my god we're having
a good time it's the adventures of
Waterworld
oh right remember that famous scene from
the movie when Dennis Hopper shot a
discus somebody and then hung out with
his mutant crab I may have
I'm an and this is this movie would have
been much more enjoyable if they did
have animals oh look I get sheepish at
you bro go ahead fire away ready yeah
look at that close yeah yeah let's see
what this looks like a catapult oh you
were the net just like they do at sea
this is crazy dude you see now it rolls
and you're happy you don't care that it
doesn't go on the wall and this goes up
like this opens and it swings up and it
goes dit dit dit dit and it swings this
way things around and [ __ ] and that's
how I used to sail it yes and then this
is like imagine how much more fun it
would be with a figure no Maya was
having more fun like this oh it's pretty
big bigger than I expected I know at the
same time it's from a movie that
everyone the same thing they were like
it's it was bigger than we expected a
bigger flop they thought it was gonna be
huge and then it died but it made over a
hundred million bucks man which is
saying something I enjoy it I think
they're cool toys I wish I wish I made a
movie made as much as Waterworld just
once I wish I made Waterworld people
really you made that piece of show bag
yes it made a hundred million dollars
watch this oh I missed again
we got the playset which is pretty
massive man I mean he was closer to what
he said is more of a Millennium Falcon
than it isn't actually but now that we
got it out you be that you be the
Mariner as portrayed by Kevin Costner
look at this three points of
articulation kids there's a figure worth
playing with you three four five enough
Wow Luke gets Kenner's bagula
Kenner but boy but you didn't start they
did Star Wars yes Kenner yeah and you
notice that the Star Wars don't have
this GI Joe a comfortable grip into the
robot well they don't have the confu
[ __ ] they must Kenner must be against
that
well Kenner was back in the day and
Hasbro bought Kenner and they let
kenner man that was the name of my
childhood meant happiness if you saw
this word that that and a UPC symbol
like you you knew you were in four good
times because you could send in the
symbols mail away and get a free figure
they didn't get that far in water world
man water well they were like send us
the UPC we'll give you your money back
because we're so sorry all right so what
seem we're gonna do so this is right
when he just backhands a little girl for
waving the plane
why is that your favorite part of the
movie like I love woody needs children
but we don't have the girl so let's
leave her out of it
it's impossible to play water wall
because all of Waterworld is set in
motion by Tina mandarine oh and she's
not represented here was there girl
tattoo on the back she's a girl she's
the point of the whole adventure you'd
get all these figures and your mama be
like go play Waterworld you'd be like I
can't and my mother would be progressive
she'd be like well this is Tina majorie
no tiger
yeah just make pretend and I'd be like I
don't have an imagination that that
would prove out years later with my
movie career all right you ready to play
this yes let's do it
you built the trimaran so you're that
I'm gonna be this bad boy all right
there's no more missiles smokers are
coming smokers you remembered that they
were called smokers
oh yeah prob you know way too much about
this movie so he runs around
oh wait see I don't know why you got
wheels on yours mine doesn't even have
wheels so I have to imagine have to use
my imagination all right man face me all
right top speed the sparkles are common
if Y is your guy facing the pole not
looking at danger come in there I'm like
I got ya then this pulls up look as
you're getting pulled up to top so now
you need me you took the figure away
yeah fun and then he's up here and he
poses B and bags out he's like Eden I
won a lot of yam bags work in your game
do you remember what do you remember
about the beginning of the movie urine
and filters what do you want is gonna
harmless question Bob what do you mean
so that's how I write because there's no
water to drink so he had to use some
kind of filter to pee through and filter
it out
let's reenact that scene dude you've got
the Mariner alright he's alone by
himself nobody's around to see so we
won't get public bit syndrome the only
one who's here to watch is the nudist
crooked so he's paint now ma'am you ass
and then he swings around onto this and
then he jumps on this and shoots across
oh so he's to jump to the night I was
the awesome if he could though right it
wouldn't like play with you as a kid you
had good ideas and stuff didn't you do a
lot I'd like to tie strings in this ring
and no you know if they didn't do it in
the movie I didn't do it for being my
own you'd make one out of yarn yeah yeah
yarn cardboard boxes with trapdoors and
such all I loved it that's why I like
this torx I feel like you can get all
that type of imagination you could swing
on things you can move things you can
have fun and shoot things if you got
your Kevin Costner action figure you
could play any number of Kevin Costner
oriented movies like Dances with Wolves
you could play if you got a Kevin
Costner action figure you know you can
play what black and white people into
the gripping family drama black and
white which came out last year where
he's like I want to be able to adopt
black kids and like you're Costner and I
don't see the movie I got that from the
commercial you could totally play that
game mullet and that one doesn't matter
but that would mean way better if you
had a mullet and here's the oppor action
figure for when you do want to play blue
velvet hmm what are these listen to your
kids all that stuff Oh classic cinema
yeah David Lynch you haven't seen it
anyway that's what was in the box this
week yes I will say it was the joy the
magic of the Waterworld tourists was
watching you all thank you and putting
this together like I have not seen you
that quiet in months you're just you
were into it man now I realize I just
gotta keep handing the models things I'm
gonna shut you up on my gear put this
together look okay excellent job man you
want to see us open more stuff maybe
four movies that you might have heard of
please let us know man go to Twitter
tell us screen junkies on Twitter on
their Facebook page you could email them
and then or you can send us stuff that
you want to see us open up man even if
it's like my pants bureau up my pants
we'll do it come here we'll open your
pants they'll be so sexy and stuff well
but anything you want we're gonna open a
lot more stuff next week right here on
our show until then I'm Kevin Smith
Jason come back next week man find out
what's in the box what's in the box
[Music]
you